hello everyone welcome my name is
antoine i am serious for cloud
by bull has doubled in dublin for two
years now so bigtable you
know it is this
massive database project that we use
internally at google that is used  to
store all that is needed for
search for maps for gmail etc
cloud bigtable it is our cloud offer
of this same product
which therefore makes it possible to store
petabytes of data and to respond to
several million requests per
second so what is it  what does it mean to
be and serious for a project like
cloud bigtable what
exactly does this job have to be serious
that's what I'm going to try to
answer today
the purpose of this presentation is  is to
introduce you to this profession of sr them who
we are what we do why
there is and what can we bring you
then to start to start a
little history in 2003 2004 google was
still  a company  quite classic
in which the
dave and prod environments were quite separate in
terms of desvres the devs therefore
designed and implemented a
project and the prod teams took care of
low dialysis in prod2 the control of the
monitoring of  the management of
updates etc and of the obvious machines and
it was that it had gone prod it was
fairly classic trades so indeed an
ingenious network system administrator
in the classic way companies
operate this format there to move
more
the  one of the first is that it's a
very classic format is well known
so there's a lot of documentation on
how to operate correctly
there are a lot of open source tools that
aim to address these
same issues for us  terms of hiring
it's quite easy since there are a lot
of people who have this profile there there was
just one major drawback to this
approach to their production it is a
problem of scale and c  Roughly growth
in 2004 we measured and the number
of engineers which was necessary to
maintain two production platforms
had a growth which was
linear according to the number of users and
a growth which was linear
according to the complexity of the projects to be
maintain the problem is that suddenly
over time we had a growth
that was ultra linear and in 2004 we
did the calculation
if they continued to operate our
production in the same way it would have
taken in 2014 a
thousand  engineers to maintain the
platform which just wasn't realistic so
we had to find a new
approach to production that they
could manage on the scale of google
which since then the growth has been
slightly higher than what had been
anticipated since since there is a
google cloud
this new approach has been chosen
it has been to treat production
as a software problem
everything absolutely has to be automated  more
automated where we need to have
engineers who manage everything manually
this approach the big change
was to treat this
production once again as a
development problem and therefore no longer
to hire people who are
administrators  systems or
network engineer but people who are
primarily software engineers finally the
development of all these tools
necessary for automation but who
at the same time is this double
skill
this ability to understand and
solve problems operational problems
so these people  with somewhat hybrid profiles,
both a developer but with
system r administration skills,
we are the locks and it is
therefore fortunate for saïd djinnit the
usual translation into French his site reliability engineers
the idea is  that we occupy the
second part of the life of a project
many people make the mistake of believing
that a project once it has been  é design
and and that it has been implemented but it
's finished and it's just not true
once implement them that it is and
it is and it's ready
that's where its second life  begins and
the second life is all the part where
it is necessary when it is necessary to deploy it it is
necessary there it is necessary to maintain it it is necessary
to update it it is necessary to repair it if
problems and it started there in fact we
surrendered  account in google that it
represents between 40 and 90% of the work
on a project so we will try
we take care of this second part
the operational maintenance of a
project of which somewhere we have a role
which is a little bit hybrid one
half of  work is therefore an
operational approach
we respond to alerts we are on call
we respond to tics and customers we
manage update issues
here we have a real ethics really
operational but the other half of our
work
this  unique
development problem therefore to develop t  All
the tools necessary
to automate everything we do
in the operational part
we are in this situation a little bit
a little bit ambiguous where half of our
work aims to make the other half
completely obsolete so what I  I
said there about this idea of having an appro
ch to production which focus
s on development it's not uniqu
to google you've heard of de
oxx years ago the question of the diffe
ence between being serious and devel
ping is  a ve
thorny question and I'm not going to try to
answer this question today
but for five extremely simple it is
customary to say that votes are a
rather abstract set of principles and
that s is rush is a
possible implementation a  sphere possible versions
a way of doing development so
here is a serious we are its
somewhat hybrid engineers who both
support has no form and develop
the tools necessary to no longer
have  maintaining it the measure of our
work is reliability
once again so now the
title of our other job kébé says is
a concept that is quite vague there are
several several elements that
flow from it
availability is what our
service is  is available
is it is is that they
respond quickly is it
efficient
is it resistant to
change beyond that reliability
means that we are also  included
for questions of advice in
quotes in the box to know that
any project that will be put into
production must first be approved
by the sr them who will take care of its
maintenance
so it is our expertise that is
recognized  before for any project that
will sort out fraud and in the same way
we are involved in all the
decisions of supply
ensures the question of how much what becomes of
the server is what we want for this
product there so put  in key  uster is what
we want replication because the
operating margin is what we reserve
all these questions there which go to a
concrete impact on the material which will
be necessary
it is we who make these decisions these
decisions there since it is  t is
ultimately up to us who are responsible for the
reliability of the product
on the whole reliability is our goal
but our mode of operation is
risk management
there are two major quotes which
roughly sum up this approach the first bench
and  both are there but the first
is always hoping that everything goes
well
always very for the worst and the
second is hope is not a
valid strategy
so that's what that's what
we are serious so I talked
about a taste for reliability I'm going to try to
define more concretely what
that means how we measure it what
objective measurement we have
but before that there are two main
principles that govern our activity
the first  those  t that reliability is
the most important feature the most
important feature of a
product if you have a
perfect application that exactly meets the
needs of your customers
but it is not reliable no
one is going to use it  because no one
will trust me
reliability is a movie show qua
non of the success of an application
so this is our most important
principle reliability first and second
principle is also important
second principle is also
important reliability this n  it's not us
who measure the reliability that counts
it's what our users see
if a client of our cloud platform
comes to us saying but your
latency is much higher than
what you promise that we look at and
tell me  says oh well no we what we measure
is good it's not acceptable
the only woman any kind of reliability that
counts is the one our customers
see so I talked a lot about
reliability  I'm going to try to give
some tools we have to have a
more objective, more
concrete approach to reliability.
are the
French terms for these terms I
don't even know if the French high school for
these terms so I'm going to use tam
English and binds these are the
indicators single service had the idea
is that we're going to choose a few
key metrics that allow us to
see how our
product works as we use
such experience
if if I take a random example I
take a platform that allows our
users to watch cat videos
like youtube for example and  a
few key measures that allow us to
see how reliable our platform is
going to be availability
how many minutes per month
our product is accessible
how latency is going to be  how long
does it take to respond to a
request from our users
it will be the bandwidth to how
many users can we send
a video in parallel these measurements
will allow us to see to what extent
our  product is reliable obviously it
's not the only thing that we are
going to release me
but the one that we are going to ester are the
metrics that we are going to choose as being
the most representative of a reliability
on the basis of  these indicators
we can define our
objectives what our product is committed to
what products will provide in
terms of reliability
it can be for example on
availability
we are committed to having a product that
will be accessible 99  95% of the time on
latency issues we can have
gradual goals like random example
90% of new docks take at
least 200 milliseconds 99% of our
queries take back at least 300
milliseconds something like that what
our goals  are therefore a
strong commitment made to
users to say this is what
our service will provide but
what happens if our service does
not fulfill its objective this is where we
need third level the
thresholds  agreements then there we are less
in the field of engineering we are no
longer in the financial or legal field
even the question is the salaries
answer the question what is happening it
is the service does not fulfill its
objectives then all the services
not two eye tests for example
google search does not have if you were on
a search with the search does
not work we do not reimburse you on the
other hand we have a direct impact for us
so do not have  need sun at this
level for an internal project
questions in the lands don't make
sense but an ace and the eye might
not be if a team fails to
fill its rooms we fail to
have to issue an  product that fulfills
its objectives
that p  had to be and the sun can be a
managerial decision of we reorient
the team to put more mayer tests
but a better pipe line on our
things and obviously for our
external customers a test the eye can take the
form of a financial reimbursement
for people who invest in their
platforms if the platform does
not deliver the performance that we promised of the
three the most important thing is the fc lauw
in the sense that it is what
very clearly defines the objective that we are aiming for
guarantees therefore we will promises you we will
provide
it is essential to have a water test
because if a service does not have to
leave the water in fact it has one but it
a water test implicit in  know that
many users consider that the
past performance is what the
service undertakes to provide
in short in the absence of an
explicit contract if I define my own
service and at the beginning I have very few
functionalities  I have very
few users and all my
re  quests take less than 50
milliseconds perfect
six months the internal objective but not
public that means well me I
manage I just manage so that
all my requests take less than a
second
I will work to maintain this
objective there but  that i'm not going to
communicate clearly to my
low users as my service
starts to grow i have more
features i have
more users and suddenly my
service starts to slow down and i don't
start i start to  respond to
requests together 200 300 milliseconds well
I'm still consistent with
what I had chosen I had chosen
Thursday less than a second
but since I will not be clearly
communicated to my users they are
starting to see a slowdown know
that  some of them may have
started to depend on
me responding in less than 50
milliseconds at first having a clear commitment
having clear
goals  avoid this kind of problem or
users depend on something
one is not able to provide in the
long run
so as always the clearer the goal
is the one where are well formulated
giuly are concise the better they are
again  series too confusing
fonfon that users risk
making expectations that are not
realistic
I slipped you this is the most important
when I presented I will start
with the employees because that is what
they come in  therefore first in
the hierarchical order but it would be a
mistake to believe that we define
our water tests according to its
size but it would be a mistake to
believe that we define our water tests
according to its lives  that opposite have
defined the objectives of our service
and according to that we define what we want to
measure to guarantee that we will achieve
this objective the fairs also go
beyond the fair of the contract with
the user it is also  t an
internal contract in the sense that it is on the
basis of water tests we will define all
our logic of alerting and well a moment
when we are on call and we will have to
make the choice to wake up an engineer
4  in the morning to tell him
something is broken in production and the
golden rule of alerts
is to always alert on the
symptoms not on the causes his in
engineers is dreaming at four in
the morning with a message that says  well we
use a little too much cpu on the
greenhouses that doesn't say anything does
it change anything for the
users is that the seven times
more errors more latency no
idea the golden rule is  to alert
about symptoms the latency increases
might soon no longer fulfill our
contract
and the bastards provide a way
to measure that and so are a great
example of how to set our alerts
so obviously it's a habit and
that's setting wings  to interns
more  strict than to
external ones and suddenly that alerts on our
internal networks rather than on the saddle
or external so to stop before having
broken our contract with the users on our side
but there is a risk if we have ideas
a  nerd too strict compared to a
bastard a term too strict compared
to the external one it is that
again of the expectations of the users which
does not correspond to what the service
provided in practice I put this genius
with subjects but  who will have to wait for
the next slide so here it is and
this is also this lot and it provides us
with a practical framework that
allows us to have a
concrete approach to this notion of reliability
on the basis of these indicators
we can define the budgets of  error
while you the budget should we
often talk about availability objective
so dave rensing who is head of the
crs section with us which I will talk about
later when he presents
on what makes  a performance and
he's talking about budgets errors he's
talking about requested uptime targets
in the room who here is
responsible for a project that has a
100% uptime target and to
all the people raising their hands
he says i wouldn't dare to do that but he
says you're wrong
you're wrong that's not realistic
the idea is that a project will
never be 100% reliable the custom of saying
that even the sun is not  not 100% reliable
and all the people against having the
sun in the solar can tell you that
there are eclipses and the cloud
even the sun itself is not 100%
reliable so aim for 100%
objectivity  objective of 100
% availability is not dooming oneself
to
failure suddenly you have to choose a
reasonable objective but which one to choose
there are several elements that will
come in which will come into account in
the choice of a realistic objective we
tend  to measure the availabilities
according to  of the number note of 9 3 9 and in
99 9% 4.9 and in 99 99 % etc
the problem is that the cost necessary
to obtain a reliability
of 4.9 or 5.9 is an
exponential depending  of the number of nine know that
the corner dia if we want to be even more
reliable we were in the past we need
more machines for I have the residence
we have to pay the engineers who
suddenly go to on-call duty with and with a
time of  much weaker reaction
it takes all the development time all the
soft said needs the tray
which allows not to require
human intervention for
I moreover there is a material cost
some have a higher reliability
of major consideration which
allow which are important and to be taken into
account it is also the question of in
addition to the sudden what is important
for our users
because otherwise users are on a
telephone network for example qualified
authorized which barely reaches the 3  9
is useless  pay this absolutely
enormous blow to arrive at saint cannat
sociability if the network on which they
are not even put will not allow them
to exceed 3 9
it is part of the things which come into
account in the choice
the other thing the most important blow
in terms of reliability
it's the opportunity cost if you
make a perfect product that
exactly meets your
users' needs and you spend
years tweaking it to be
reliable at 5.9
but it comes out three  years after the
products of your competitors well, the
product in question is not very useful
the opportunity cost is a cost in
time and time this is something that
we can never recover after this
question of velocity
or  do we place the cursor between
taking risks to go fast and
being very careful being reliable this is a
question that everyone knows we are
all fond of the boxes where there were
the development teams that there
were  t a project that absolutely wanted
for the hope of its current projects this
project in production to be able to deliver
their new functionalities with
opposite production teams worried
about the reliability which on the contrary
it said no we take as much we do
more  test we want a more
reliable project this master is that this slider
between speed between velocity and caution
is a very classic problem and this
is where the nozzles and errors
come into action
what is it  is that the budget
for errors and quite simply this
order is six other products undertakes
to say well we will be available 99 9%
of the time
to say to ourselves that at 43 minutes per month in
which our product cannot is not
available  without that we have without that we
have not fulfilled our team contract
all our projects measure this
error budget to know how much this
margin of error that we can afford
we have used and this indicator is
extremely useful for  several things  its
dont for example wants to choose this slider
between between velocity and caution in a
sense this error budget it's a
dummy of quantifying the risk which
is absolutely essential a way so a
lot of equips use these decide
if the team
every  months absolutely not using its
error budget enough maybe a
team that is not taking enough risks
maybe it's a team that could
afford to deliver projects
faster to bring features
to market faster
Conversely, a team that every month
uses its entire
error budget and that every month is at the
limit of not fulfilling its past contract,
maybe a team that should
slow down a bit pronotum but test and
provide a project  more reliable
once again it's error budget
makes it possible to quantify the risk and
it is absolutely essential so this
idea of using them to be able to manage the v
locity is not the only way to us
error budgets I was
talking about the previous phase of an
anecdote that illustrates both the
problem when you have one and the other
strictly a bastard and his internal laws
too strict compared to the external and
which illustrates another  how to
use buses and errors we have a
project is one called chebbi if
you are familiar with zookeeper the
page it's pretty much stable after the
same idea it's really a
distributed systems [ __ ] project  the ways this
ticket is implemented internally we have
a global instance and local instances
replicated the sl at the ankles and
quite good but the season and the
internal one is even stricter and
as it is a relatively
silent project but which has  no need to push a
lot of features
it is a project that in the past has
proven to be extremely reliable much more
reliable than what it is indicated
and as a result some
internal developers have made the mistake of not
respecting  cter what the documentation said
and to depend directly on the
global instance whereas the dic while the
documentation says very clearly you
must not depend on it you must
depend on local instances
it was a problem since there was a
risk  the day there was a real
problem on chebbi what a lot of
service is suddenly more
available so to fix it is
to use something funny
athens called dirt dope ses for
disaster recovery testing or in  big
two ways in general annual
without warning the teams concerned
in a controlled environment we will
voluntarily break something in
production to see how the
system reacts how people
react
is that our system is reliable and
able to overcome a difficulty in
production by  obviously it's still
a real controlled environment we can
stop the experiment before our
users are impacted may  s here and
we do that in general without warning the
teams concerned
what ankle did what the
waitresses of chebbi did one year within the
framework of offers and that it is now necessary
on a regular basis it was at the  end
of a month or a quarter I don't know
anymore they took the entire goal
and errors remaining there is the rest and I
don't know how many minutes 5 6 minutes
of game errors and they cut
l  'global instance and they looked at
which projects were no longer working, it
delighted him to see immediately and in a
controlled framework he could restart the
service immediately if there
was a risk that our customers
allowed us to immediately see which
projects had done  this error of
depending on the global sense
all that was another and another
example the use of error budget
where you can afford to
experiment because you know exactly
quantified how viable the service is
or  not so that's it for the
drunk  dgets of errors which are the key it is
another job so until now I
have spoken a lot about technical things the
only ones to leave there the water is salty etc
the goals and errors but is serious
it is not  just a practical approach
it's above all a culture it's a
way of understanding production and on
several occasions it seems important
to me to highlight that I highlighted
on seven this live the first it  is that we
are above all development teams
we work in collaboration
with development teams doing
operational work must represent
less than 50% well 50% maximum of our
time so that does not mean that if
we ever have too many things to deal with  in
production we will just stop to
respond to alerts no longer respond to
tickets no we will continue to do
so on the other hand if a team spends more than
50% of its time
doing operational work it is a
very strong sign for management
what  something is wrong  object
is not reliable enough there is a problem
in the team this
is a very negative sign a team
is never if you have spent more than
50% of hearing from us that its time
doing operational work and the
reason  is that beating
operational labor conflict within the
short term project
we are just to maintain the platform
in the state while the goal of
development is projects the long
term is to let aim once
again to  automation to no longer
need this short-term work
the second point which seems to me
extremely important underlined in
this culture is the idea of learning from
ur mistakes we have a culture of post-
ortems I have not so  you are
familiar with this practice but the idea
is that after any incident in
production we establish a strict post mortem
which determines what
happened what was their departure
what was the the chain of
reactions of events what was
the impact po  ur our users
cunha money is not lost and that's
the most important point n'a post mortem it's
zack snyder what do we do what
do we decide to do like
spying on fishing  jean of error to
happen in the future and the key to all and
post mortem and some
key points of our culture it's no
post mortem not looking for a culprit
we're not looking to blame someone we're
not looking  to assign the fault
then you are going to tell me but sometimes it
is someone who made a mistake
there is a developer who introduces a
bug in the code there is someone who
calls the wrong command line
with the wrong flag and has  reached ten
thousand server is someone who made
a mistake somewhere yes but our
approach to say if the system doesn't have
the safeguards in place to prevent this
kind of mistake from happening it's the
system that  is a problem by the
person obviously it is because we
assume we are all in the aisne d  in the
same team we don't assume that no one
has bad intentions but
again if a well-meaning person
makes a mistake it's a
system problem it's that the system did not
prevent this person from making a
mistake
an example of this my mentor in my team
two years ago when i joined the company two years ago tell me that
in his first three months at google
he caused he caused a major incident
in production he called the wrong in
of orders the cause of major incidents
he spent several days worrying
is he going to get fired for this
he received a bonus he received a bonus
because his mistake revealed a flaw
that we don't  was not aware of
the fact what are teeth because
of an incident allowed to see the flaw
to understand it to correct it and to
allow the platform to be more
more resistant and to this kind of error
to no longer  never arrive to the future
he received a bonus it  is an
absolutely essential part of our culture we have
to learn from our mistakes and the
best the best way to do
that is not to be assigned since
mobility the last thing it's managed in
a balanced way and on-call on-
call is horribly stressful
having to be having to wait at night with
the phone in case you get
called is not the most
fun part of the job and it is extremely
important and have joined a little
mobilize and this thanks to part
of a team must  never spent more than
50% of his time doing
operations joined this idea
of minimizing the high so possible the p
nalties and assets germany has as ba
anced as possible so that the t
am does not burn out there are several ways
to do this the way i have
this in my team since our team
is split between new york and dublin on
call only 12 o'clock
for us this 6 am to six
o'clock  evening for them is to come
from afternoon to one o'clock in the morning
but which means that no one is
ever on call at 3 o'clock in the morning
there is always with 1:30
but it is never  3 must have lost that this
morning for this person there and so
many other services rotate
around December 31 so that
no one is ever on call at
midnight in their time zone
there is always someone on call
but he  is never midnight for the
person who is on call to
leave everyone even even
on call to see December 31 at
midnight free water so here it is above all
to you who is due seriously even if
it is  your risk management and even if
it's a commitment in terms of
reliability,
it's above all a culture with
principles that allow us
to learn at this level, you're going to
tell me, but everything I'm saying so far is
is in no way specific to google and
you are absolutely right in none
of this is  st specific to google is
once again the d box movement is
quite close and it is this same day two
principles applied more
generally and we did not arrive at this
result of the sr e teams and all
its principles of this  culture
ex nihilo there have been ten years 12 years 15 years
almost now of looking for
work to achieve this result and we
are at a point today we feel that
we have to share this result what
we happen that  'we learned it was
sometimes painful,
well our industry will only be
better if we share with
everyone we have chosen several approaches
for this we have written a book and asnières
which is available in French which
details  much more
precisely than I have what I've done
so far
how a production works what we
tried what didn't work what we
tried that worked
how we learned about this
experience  is chosen for example
beyond that we also do
conferences like this have been
in practice for a year now,
but officially for a year now we have
launched a new initiative whose
goal is to help our customers have
better reliability on our products,
this initiative is the  'initiative cf
the idea by the way that is that our
industry is rather good at
convincing companies and
companies to switch to cloud
computing or in front of your merits of the cloud
everyone goes to the club very well
but we are many  less good at
explaining to companies how to do
cloud computing correctly how
to see how to properly manage their
production how to have
reliable applications so a lot of
cloud platform providers
believe that the division of
responsibilities and very clear that the
platform their responsibilities and but
that the reliability of the applications
is yours you customers at google we believe
that it is not so simple and that
the interac  tion between the applications and
the platform means that somewhere we have
a share of responsibility in the
reliability of your applications esma
decided this violence to this initiative
of these happy so that this path to
the truth engineering or a team of s
is re going to talk  to the
production teams of our customers to help
them improve the reliability of their
applications on our platform
we usually say in terms of
internally joking is to say that
the test re are ds and re who have the
very rare genetic mutation  which makes
them like to talk to people about
weird people
and in short here is this idea is that we are
going to support our customers could
help them to have better performance
and better reliability on the
platform
there are several steps to that  it takes
several several there are several levels
of partnership level 1 is just
a level of analysis and review
of applications at the very beginning of the
launch of the project  and it's fortunate
it was something very
monolithic apply the comic that lives
old we recently changed so that it
is finally something more modular
that we can adapt to the needs of our
customers
but the idea is that it  is someone
somewhere between consulting
and analysis where we will talk with
our customers' teams for several
months to analyze their applications to
see how to help them have
better reliability
it mainly consists of asking the
difficult questions what reliability  what are
you aiming for
what reliability what you have
now prove what are your
free trials what are your
water trials what are you measuring
yours monitoring is what is
correct what is  it is in line with
what you hope for in terms of
performance and therefore to do all this
work to bring a very expert is
in terms of happiness to the teams of our
customers obviously we are not at
all saying  that you're bad
you don't know how to manage production that's not
our approach at all it's just to
say not to us we have 10 years of experience
on how to manage large-scale systems
we share this experience with you
so  that's level 1
support you on the analysis of your
applications for customers who
want to go further level 2
is to build a common
platform and a
monitoring platform the  idea is to have a
single monitoring platform that is
common to us and our customers say that
we bring all the metrics
we have from our platform and our
customers bring to this platform
all the customer metrics that has two
advantages  enormous
the first is that it makes it possible
to identify the problems which
occur in a much
faster way to all had this problem of a customer
who counts is that it is someone from
the i lombard platform we have  sees the
latency increased so m
drastic way and the person at the atom
who says yes but no we don't see it if
the monitoring and the same if the boss
at the meeting is the
same both the engineers on both sides
both on the client side and on the platforms
can see the  metric and can see
where the problem is
it also allows to have a
much faster reaction time because
in the case where the two beasts a domain
of meetings are separated and the
problem is only seen on the client side
the client realizes  that there is a problem
he opens a country like Italy
on the one hand an engineer is alerted
opens a ticket on the client side contacts
the platform opens a ticket on
the platform side someone from
support retrieves the ticket from you will contact  an
engineer the reaction time is
relatively high whereas if the
monitoring platform and the same
between the client and the platform beats we
can we can take a shortcut and
have something that
automatically creates  a quota a ticket with
us it is a metric on your side
finds that there is a problem which
obviously decreases annoying the
reaction time and allows to have a better
total reliability
the mtt ya that I mention on spain
c  is the mend time to recovery
how long on average we take
before solving a problem so this is the
second level we build together
with our customers a platform which
allows us to have a monitoring share
a metric such as a measure of  the
quality of this platform platform
is correct there should be
no alerts that they are
based on a metric that is not in
this platform know that otherwise we have
internal alerts  on the two
all-thematic platforms on
which these salaries are based
must be a common platform we
do not hide anything from our customers is the
same way if our hall customers
is a term because they believe that
their reliability is  important it's a
trick must be in this platform
in common so that we can be
alerted immediately a problem
that's level 2 level 3 to go
even further
consists in doing all the
post-mortem exercises together with
our clients' teams the idea is that any
problem that has an impact and
their performance is a problem that
concerns us and any problem that
impacts them platform that
impacts and had problems that
concern them so everything  this
post-mortem exercise
what happened where it stalled because
of the bug what was the impact
what are we doing now these
exercises from this level we
do it together with our clients
a  extremely important point to post
mortem I earlier all post
mortem must have access and m in the
event that these post mortem with our customers
any post mortem to have
alten actions on each side with us as
with the  customers you go to me  say but
sometimes there is an error that comes
from us it's just we watch for
little availability or 16 errors come
that the customer was fine only to launch
a new order etc changed the
level I don't have the number  servers
on platforms and many times
when there is
only one side's responsibility, well,
not really in the sense that if the
problem is on our side, our
platform has not been reliable and well
maybe  that we can help
our customers can we can help
our customers to improve their
applications so that
they have more redundancy and so
that it is more reliable in the event that
the  platform does not respond and
if it is someone from the application
who made a bad manipulation
we can also improve our system
to prevent this kind of bad manipulation
has happened in the future in theory this
post mortem does  in common must how to
say must result in d  the activities on
each side for the teams that want to
go even further,
we have therefore already done this whole
review process with whom we have shared this monitoring
and with whom we do all the
post-mortems in common can choose
to go to the level  next and where in the end
our on-call rotations are almost
are almost a single unique rotation
with the basic idea if you have a
problem
at 3 a.m. and the fact that
start war room at 3 a.m.
because  your application does
not behave as you want we
accompany you we are there our engineers
work with you and the idea is
that we want
suddenly we also involve you in
all our dirt exercises as old
were elsewhere where is going  voluntarily
breaking something to measure the
reliability of the platform and in
the exercise of missions which are the same
thing but in a framework where we are not really going to
break the reform just simulate
an incident and see co  how does the
product react so that's it that's
happy this initiative or since we
now have almost 15 years of experience
in how to operate
large-scale production systems we share
this experience with your customers in
the  aim of guaranteeing better
reliability of your applications on our
platform two interesting cases
obviously I do not want to quote too many
customers who are not that they are an
audience and I do not want to quote a lot
of figures but two examples which
seem interesting to me  very first
customer we had with whom we had
this experience of these happy people was
pokemon go i have not so sony from the
pokemon gold launch last but the
launch was a bit chaotic
because they had a  outsized success
by having what they had anticipated and
their system was not ready to
take the low load of the number
of users they are educating
suddenly it was a first customer
we did all this t  work with them to
do any analysis of their products
to see how to improve the reliability
of construction and a joint monitoring
to be able to help them overcome this
difficulty from the start our other large
public customer his sheets or 10 inches in
the United States with with him we  did
all scales the four courses they
have on the way they
retransformed all of their to the
production teams to adopt a rather
street model so the same I do not want to
give figures but they communicated the
asnières after black friday to
announce that  it was black friday a
country with the highest sales volume
has the lowest error rate since
they have been using the platform
so here we are in the face and that is
russell our mission to support our
customers
and something  important so I'm not
seen enough myself so I don't know
what the eligibility criteria are anymore
but it's rough a free service it
's not something on the  what
we charge our customers is
something we do voluntarily
since we believe that the reliability of our
customers is our reliability
to sum up it serves them it is a
new approach to production where we
deal with the  projection as being a
software problem and where
automation forgiveness automation makes it possible to manage
a very large scale production
it is principles but it is above
all a culture and it is the result
of years and years  of practice
and testing and learning and we were
reaching a weight now where it is
estimated that 20 for a butt our
industry it is important to share
this learning remains and have
announced initiatives as it is
happy to
share  share this experience and
that's all i have for you
today
thank you very much
[applause]